it was fine flying weather but still the
Boeing 737 crashed tiny pieces of debris
were all it left behind the pilot sent
out a distress signal and then just six
minutes after takeoff the plane hit the
ground in nairobi kenya people gathered
to wait for flight 302 his arrival but
it never landed at first there was
confusion and complaints about the lack
of information Addis Ababa Ethiopia as
the afternoon wore on a sickening
realization set in for passengers loved
ones those who departed there on Sunday
morning we're never coming home so there
is a very sad and tragic day for all of
us attitude penitence and for our
passengers
Ethiopia Civil Aviation Authority is now
tasked with leading the probe
investigators hope to find clues amid
the mangled wreckage explaining how this
new Boeing plane could crash so fast
answers to this tragedy which can't come
fast enough for Ethiopians they've been
gathering at the crash site the shock
and grief this is caused is writ large
on the faces of people there well I
correspondant know only occurred the
ball joins us now from Nairobi where
that flight was heading know any good
morning to you details have been
emerging of who was on that flight what
do we know this morning
fren we know that people from all over
the world were on this plane according
to European airlines Kenya has the
highest number of casualties 32 Kenyans
were on board followed by Canada with 18
Gopa lost nine and the u.s. Italy and
China all had eight Nationals on board
as well the list of their names has been
published and of course we're learning
more and more about the people behind
these numbers one of them for example
was Cedric a CF Hooper he was born and
raised in Mombasa he was a law student
in DC and he was on his way to Nairobi
because his fiance's mother had died
someone else was in Ethiopian aid worker
called Tamra Malou lemme see he was
working with safe the children and his
colleagues described him as someone who
tirelessly worked to save vulnerable
children and humanitarian crises and of
course these are just a few of the
stories the personal stories behind
these numbers of the people who lost
their lives yesterday in this tragic
crash know only one day after the crash
along with all of these personal stories
what's the mood where you are I'm here
at the airport this is where flight 83
are to Bosh a do to land yesterday at
10:30 in the morning this is where
relatives family friends colleagues had
all been waiting for hours for a plane
that never arrived hundreds of people
gathered here yesterday relatives were
attended to in emergency centers but a
lot of people had also just come out in
support today the mood is sad the iPod
looks a lot more quiet than usual up and
talking to a few people said that
they're more anxious than ever waiting
for their loved ones to arrive today we
do not have confirmation yet but it
looks like the President himself could
be heading out to the airport today I've
been seeing military and ceremonial
uniform while in the meantime on social
media there is an outpouring still of
messages of condolence and you can
really feel that the entire country all
of Kenya is mourning DW is Melanie Kurd
the ball for us in Nairobi
at the airport where that flight was
headed thanks very much for that Melanie
our aviation editor Kristoff Coburn
joins us now for more on this good
morning
christophe china has decided as a result
of this crash to ground all of its at
737 max eights that's right the Civil
Aviation Administration says and about
two hours from now
all 96 737 max aircraft that are
operated by Chinese carriers need to
stay on the ground until further notice
the authority says this is in line with
the principle of zero tolerance for
security risks now this move is quite
significant because it applies to about
one-fourth of the global 737 max fleet
and it comes after Ethiopian Airlines as
well as Cayman Airways have also
grounded their 737 max fleet meanwhile
Boeing says it has no new guidance for
the operators of this aircraft
okay so Safety's of course are important
for Boeing is it and the airline type
the Boeing 737 is a work force for so
many airlines around the world what can
you tell us about the max 8 version well
it's a new generation of this type of
plane
it's Boeing's fastest selling plane
about 350 models are in operation right
now more than 5,000 have been ordered
because it's supposed to be more fuel
efficient it also features new software
so it's it's somewhat represents not
only the future of flying for Boeing but
also the future for the company now this
is the second time this exact same type
of aircraft has crashed we saw lion
airlines and about what four or five
months ago a similar crash there
Indonesia is there any link or is it too
early to talk about it is quite early to
talk about that however there are
similarities that are hard to ignore
both were virtually brand new planes
apart from the fact that it was this
very same type of plane both brand new
both featuring problems or facing
problems in the same stage of flight
right after takeoff and although we
should not jump to conclusions there are
some indicators that both planes behaved
similarly right before the crash and
this is raising eyebrows
and we will know more once we have the
black box the voice recorder the search
continues for that right that's right
the intensified search for these two
devices because the flight data recorder
as well as divorce recorder from the
flight deck they report hundreds of sets
of data and they can even with sand you
know really hard impact as you know in
this case happened crashing into the
ground
with flight et 302 so once these devices
are recovered which hopefully will
happen rather quickly then you know
investigators can't paint a rather
detailed picture of what happened on
this flight and Christophe we'll have
more from you later in this hour on this
story right right Christophe Cobra for
us thank you very much